hall of fame pitcher george thomas
sieber
tom terrific spent parts of 12 seasons
with the mets and remains the ball
club's leader in wins strikeouts earned
run average innings pitched and shutouts
the greatest player in team history his
nickname is fittingly the franchise
a statue in his honor will be unveiled
later this year
[Applause]
fans are back in the ballpark and they
get to watch the mets debut of taiwan
walking kaipa california meet the big
apple it was his work
in toronto six starts after he got
traded from seattle that got him that
two-year contract with the mets
three fastballs three strikes and taiwan
walker has a k in the books to start his
mets career
close it down i mean that fastball
perfectly placed
3-2 coming to rojas
and a little dribbler
walker off the mound to bare hand two
out
another really good slider by walker to
get rojas on the comeback
oh yes and now he picks off martay
alonso makes the toss
and mcneil makes the tag and that
retires the side taiwan walker picking
off starlight martay to end the top of
the first on the hill for the marlins is
nick nigert the number 15 prospect in
the marlin system according to baseball
america four games last season but all
out of the pen 14th different starting
pitcher
for miami
beat the cubs before losing to the
braves in the division series nimmo
takes one down the left field line he's
got to base it cut off by dickerson but
nimmo cruises into second base with a
lead off double
branded off to a terrific start of the
season this time fell behind in the
counter with two and he slices a double
down so now francisco lindora will take
his first hacks as ahmed at citi field
and the crowd that is here getting a
standing ovation in his first appearance
at city field as a man i'm sure that his
ovation would have equaled anybody's
lender lifts one out to left field and
dickerson is right there
[Applause]
and that's the first out
three and two to conforto and a called
strike three
and a good slider to strike out aguilar
second strikeout for walker one down in
the second different pitcher and a very
different person than he was earlier in
his career as brian anderson flies one
out to right center and nimble
but he hangs on
that ball just kept on carrying and it
fooled nimmo who was playing deep to
begin with
and he lost his footing in the last
couple of steps going back into the wall
but hung on lucky didn't hurt his neck
or shoulder
2-2 pitch again swinging a miss he
struck him out with that change up so
that's the second strike got for neither
it wasn't long at bat but he gets the
first out here in the second inning
swinging to miss 95 miles an hour from
niger gets a couple of strikeouts in the
second he's got three in the afternoon
we head to the third
and he goes down swinging on the taiwan
walker fastball third strikeout for
walker
good pitch to hit that's looking to
break through three and one to conforto
and he takes it high ball for us a
back-to-back two-out walks
set the stage for alonso
this year's alonso offers that the first
one in foul territory is aguilar waiting
for it to come down it finally does
and neither strands a pair for the
second time this afternoon
line to shoreline
rising liner and lindor rose with it
helping taiwan walker to a one two three
inning perfectly tied
ended the first inning with runners in
scoring position and he lines this one
into center field and he's got himself a
base head leading off in the fourth so
dom's hit two line drives one into a
glove and one
onto christine grass
that one skipped behind one look at a
good read by dom smith and he's at
second base he was off as soon as that
ball hit the dirt
and that's just off the plate he tried
the backdoor slider and missed
and so that's the fourth walk given up
by niner and the mets have two men on
3-2 to mccann and he misses outside ball
four so that's five walks down for niner
he had three in the third innings and
they're loaded up for walker
ground ball anderson underhand flip to
jazz over to first and again
knighter is able to wiggle out of
trouble
and anderson to right field there's the
base hit right off the end of the bat so
brian anderson has the first knock for
the marlins after walker held him
without for four and a third nice hand
for
walker two outers chad wallach who had
one of the warning track and right field
his first time up and he tops one up the
third baseline walker springs off the
mound and makes the play to retire the
side
taiwan walker helping himself out with
his defense we are halfway through in
the home opener
that's paul tori the hole in lindora's
got his first citi field hit as a met
well the key i take from that is because
of lindor's ability to go the opposite
way you don't shift them
you don't shift them you get the base
hit
that's going to be it for nick neidert
in his major league first major league
start
three and one to alonso
and pete takes inside ball four that'll
load him up
so dead wilder has come in hit a batter
walked about her base is loaded for
smith
can he watch his way out to center
martay going
back at the wall
fantastic play by martay it'll bring in
the game's first run as lindor scores
but martay saved a couple of runs with a
tremendous catch right at the fence
to rob dom smith of extra bases one
nothing new york on the dom sacrifice
fly boy oh boy and this is the tail end
of the catch he ran a long way for this
ball
one two swinging into miss strike three
well it's a run-in for the mets but it
could have been a lot more if not for a
great play by mark tay
and now john bertie into right center
field that's gonna get down to base hit
birdie came in as part of the double
switch when detweiler took over for
nighter
so in the ninth spot he leads off the
sixth with a base hit so at all costs i
would just try to get one run in here
cory dickerson to hit a roll for two so
far
and this one to right field toward the
corner gonna get down
bertie on his way to third he will get
waved around by trey hillman
gets home smoothly this time with the
marlins first run the equalizer from
corey dickerson here in the sixth
how many times i i tell you this
corey dickerson with two strikes it's a
one-two pitch people my goodness just
pulls his hands inside rips it into the
right field corner
[Applause]
pitch they'll get another right here
with algilar going to left field to base
hit to score dickerson tremendous at bat
from jesus aguilar it's 2-1 marlins
96 mile an hour fastball he's going to
rip it into left field nice job by
aguilar's vets will try and rally with
mcneil mccann and then probably
guillerme to pitch in mcneal is still
looking for that elusive first hit of
the year or for two today or for 10 to
begin the season
swinging a fly ball to right field well
hit duval back still going at the track
at the wall it's gone mcneil does it he
leads off the bottom of the ninth with a
game tying homer on and this baby's all
even two to two
well you called it howie jeff mcneal
with an opportunity to turn on a
fastball that's quite a birthday present
that is quite a first hit of the season
and these fans finally have something to
get on their feet about in the return to
city field in the home opener and jeff
mcneal ties the game here in the bottom
of the nine
[Applause]
line the other way
base hit that's gonna go
[Applause]
second opposite field double of the day
and the mitts of the winning run at
third with one out
off lindo and the door and pitched
against
the way to get out of it right here
opportunity to walk it off
one two coming
and the
[Applause]
it was a strike
but he didn't move
and mark don mattingly is going to come
out and argue the call with the home
plate on fire ron culpa
what are they saying they're saying the
play stands game's over the mets win it
wow